uh so let's talk about
programming languages if it's okay at
the highest absurd philosophical level
because i i don't get romantic on me
last year i will forever get rid of i
think
and uh torture i apologize uh
why do programming languages even matter
okay well thank you very much you're
saying why should why should you care
about any one programming language or
why do why do we care about programming
computers or
no why do we why do we care about
programming language design creating
effective programming languages
uh choosing a
you know one programming languages
versus another programming language
why we keep struggling and improving
through the evolution of these
programming languages sure okay so
so i mean i think you have to come back
to what are we trying to do here right
so we have these
these uh beasts called computers that
are very good at specific kinds of
things and we think it's useful to have
them do it for us right
now you have this question of how best
to express that because you have a human
brain still that has an idea in its head
and you want to achieve something right
so
well there's lots of ways of doing this
you can go directly to the machine and
speak assembly language
and then you can express directly what
the computer understands that's fine
you can then have higher and higher and
higher levels of abstraction up until
machine learning when you're designing a
neural net to do the work for you
the question is where where along this
way do you want to stop
and what benefits you get out of doing
so and so program languages in general
you have c
you have fortran and java and
ada pascal swift you have lots of
different things
they all have different trade-offs and
they're tackling different parts of the
problems
now one of the things that most
programming languages do
is they're trying to make it so that you
have pretty basic things like
portability across different hardware
so you've got i'm going to run on an
intel pc i'm going to run a risk 5 pc
i'm going to run on arm phone or
something like that
fine i want to write one program and
have it portable
and this is something assembly doesn't
do now when you start
looking at the space of programming
languages this is where
i think it's fun because programming
languages all have trade-offs
and most people will walk up to them and
they look at the surface level of syntax
and say oh i like curly braces or i like
tabs
or i like you know semicolons or not or
whatever right it's
subjective fairly subjective very
shallow
things but programming languages when
done right can actually be very powerful
and the the benefit they bring is
expression okay and if you look at
programming languages there's really
kind of two different levels to them one
is
the down in the dirt nuts and bolts of
how do you get the computer to be
efficient stuff like that how they work
type systems compiler stuff things like
that the other is the ui
and the ui for programming language is
really a design problem and a lot of
people don't
think about it that way and the ui you
mean all that stuff with the braces and
yeah all that stuff's the ui and what it
is and ui means user interface
um and so what what's really going on is
it's the interface between the guts
and the human and humans are hard
right humans have feelings they have
things they like they have things they
don't like and a lot of people
treat programming languages as though
humans are just kind of
abstract creatures that cannot be
predicted but it turns out that
actually there are there is better and
worse
like people can tell when a program
language is good
or when it was an accident right and uh
one of the things with swift in
particular is that
a tremendous amount of time by a
tremendous number of people
have been put into really polishing and
making it feel good
but it also has really good nuts and
bolts underneath it you said that
swift makes a lot of people feel good
how do you get to that
point so
how do you predict that you know tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are going to enjoy using
this the user experience of this
programming language well you can you
can look it in terms of better and worse
right so if you have to write
lots of boilerplate or something like
that you'll feel unproductive
and so that's a bad thing you can look
at in terms of safety if
like c for example is what's called a
memory unsafe language and so you get
dangling pointers and you get all these
kind of bugs
but then you have to spend tons of time
debugging and it's a real pain in the
butt
and you feel unproductive and so by
subtracting these things from the
experience you get um
you know happier people but uh again
keep interrupting
i'm sorry uh but it's so hard to deal
with
if you look at the people people that
are most productive on stack overflow
they are uh they have a set of
priorities yeah
that may not always correlate perfectly
with the experience of the majority of
users
you know if you look at the most upvoted
uh quote-unquote correct answer on stack
overflow
is usually really
sort of uh prioritizes like safe code
proper code stable code
you know that kind of stuff as opposed
to like if i want to use go to
statements
in my basic right uh
i'm gonna i want to use go to state like
what if 99 of people want to use go to
save so use completely improper
you know unsafe syntax i don't think
that people actually like if you boil it
down you get below the surface level
people don't actually care about
go-to's or if statements or things like
this they care about achieving a goal
yeah right so the real question is i
want to set up a
web server i want to do a thing whatever
like how how quickly can i achieve that
right and so the
from a programming language perspective
there's really two things that that
matter there
one is what libraries exist and then how
quickly can you put it together
and what are the tools around that look
like right and
and when you want to build a library
that's missing what do you do
you